if you want to hear about the original
ending of happy deathday stick around to
the end of this video
hey what's that someone sounds groggy
air what do you want to fall asleep
editing a things you list video again uh
no not at all I don't believe you but
you still down to film of the three I am
challenge tomorrow yeah sure what time
I'm hanging up now
don't forget the [ __ ] leave the $10
okay
a little bits of information and if
you're paying attention you can piece
some of that info together for example
you may notice that the date that tree
has to relive is September 18 over the
course of the movie we also pick up that
it's her birthday it's also her late
mother's birthday and it falls on a
Monday this year so we can use that
information to pretty much determine
that it takes place in the same year of
the release 2017 that date hasn't fallen
on a Monday before this year since 2006
and it won't again until 2023 given that
information I tried to see if there was
any significance to the state and found
a couple of possibilities the first is
that it's HIV Awareness Day in the
conversation with Danielle
the sorority leader girl tree has given
tips to prevent that sort of thing
there's even a version of the script
where danielle tells her to be mindful
so she doesn't contract a bacterial
infection
September 18th is also world water
monitoring day if you watched my last
video you know that I think there could
be some references to environmental
preservation
her name is tree which is a weird name
unless you're naming your character like
that for a reason her killer is always
trying to cut her down a symbol of
deforestation every day she wakes up and
goes outside where she's greeted with a
woman wearing a shirt that reads tree
huggers United the woman wants her to
sign a petition stop global warming
which she constantly ignores then the
sprinklers go off prematurely which can
directly tie back into the water
preservation thing one of the kills
literally involves killing her with a
bomb director Christopher Landon is
almost directly telling us that
pollution is killing our trees our
environment each day she only has a
limited amount of time to figure out who
her killer is just as we are running out
of time to save our environment and we
can see this in the movie despite the
fact that she gets a reset every day she
starts to feel the long-term effects of
being killed every night the doctor
tells her she can't continue like this
because she's starting to incur
permanent damage and then there's the
fact that it's her birthday and outside
of the obvious sound like of birthday
and Earth Day maybe Landon is telling us
that each year that goes by we're
killing our environment more and more if
we're not nice to our environment it's
not going to be nice to us in the future
if you're not totally convinced that she
represents the environment just look at
all the stuff in her room it's filled
with butterflies feathers pictures of
birds and stuffed animals and throughout
the movie there's the fact that there's
no tomorrow
her no future if we do too much damage
now science won't be able to save her
later
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's a comic about the drought
'yeah didn't we have this conversation
already what are you talking about
wait i'm sure about to ask me if i can
film a three i'm challenge with you yeah
you filled up yes sure why not
cool and don't forget to send me about
ten dollars there was a lot of symbolism
in the movie of relating to the time
loop that trains stuck in when she first
wakes up on the nightstand next to the
bed you'll see a book of Sudoku the
japanese number puzzles tree is trying
to solve her own puzzle in this movie
the puzzle of her own murder and like a
pseudo KU puzzle it's something that
becomes easier to solve the more that
you have filled in when she first walked
outside on campus one of the things that
always reoccurs is the guys who are
trying to stay awake for some protest we
don't really know what they're
protesting but they're always on our 26
which is a good way to tell the audience
that time isn't progressing and the one
on the right always passes out which
alludes to trees eventual exhaustion
from reading the same death over and
over and at one point passing out very
early in the day also on a side note did
anyone else think the second guy from
the right looked a lot like
comedyshortsgamer anyway went Regas did
gregory's class it seems to be some kind
of astronomy class or something i
couldn't really comprehend what the
lesson was about but it seemed like he
was talking about the orbit of the earth
which is also the benchmark that we as
humans used to measure and help us
construct our perception of time so
technically if she relives the same day
over and over
she's retreading the same part of the
path that the earth travels in its orbit
of the Sun there was a lot to take in at
the fraternity party there was so much
decoration there that I'm sure there's
stuff that I missed so let me know what
you noticed in the comments and I'm also
curious about your interpretation of the
medieval looking knight's armor in the
frat house I feel like it has something
to do with the vase full of arrows next
to laurie and trees TV but I'm not
entirely sure what's the make of it
there's also a tree of bras in the
of the room I didn't go to a big college
so if anyone can explain that it would
be appreciated it might just be
something that's used to a similar
effect of a pin-up girl which we see on
the opposite side of the room here I
feel like it might have something to do
with the fact that the place is covered
in these rooster graphics roosters are
all male and this is a house comprised
of all male college students Nick's
bedroom represents a dead end for our
protagonist there are more obvious signs
like the skull and crossbones while
there are also more subtle ones one of
the posters says tomorrow on it
haunting tree on what she cannot have
there's also a large do not enter sign
on the back of the door not only does
this tell her that she can't escape the
room but let's also consider the meaning
of a do not enter sign it's something
that tells us we have to go back from
where we came what she's doing each time
she gets killed
she resets and goes back to the
beginning of the day the sign contrasts
quite nicely with a sign that we only
see at the very end of the movie in
Carter's room a one-way sign this shows
up after the cycle has been broken and
tells us that time is only gonna flow in
one direction now she's not going to be
retracing her steps any longer she's
only going one way forward look I know
you're never gonna believe this but I
keep reliving the same day over and over
I'll believe you but you oh sure just
send me the ten dollars
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]
hey what's a come one family drug yeah
yeah well I've been stuck living the
same day over and over again I mean
that's basically what it's like working
in the fast food industry though I think
I figured it out though I need to make
the perfect things you missed video that
has to be the key to breaking the cycle
let's talk about the elephant in the
room no literally let's talk about the
elephants in the main character's room a
little elephant ornament can be found in
the corner across from the door at first
I only had my suspicions of what it
might represent but it was more or less
confirmed when I heard the director
refer to the similarity to Groundhog Day
as the elephant in the room saying that
he put in that line from Carter which
compares tree situation to that of Bill
Murray's and Groundhog Day since these
comparisons are unavoidable Landon
decided to embrace the elephants in the
room like the one in trees room under
the table in many ways happy deathday is
written as a spiritual successor to
Groundhog Day both characters wake up to
a song each morning both start off as
kind of nasty people and come to see the
error of their ways both have an arc
where they try to help everyone in the
community and both have arcs of
experimentation both have a cycle where
they try killing themselves and both
eventually learn to put others before
themselves the other elephant in the
room right now is the remote-control
scene or tree locks yourself in the room
and can't find the remote and the
channel start changing automatically it
seems very similar to my short film
remote threat role it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's the remotes
if you want to see the whole film pop on
over here you can also find evidence of
Laurie's guilt throughout the story
nobody is supposed to know when trees
birthday even is Laurie claims that she
got the info from her driver's license
but I think she's lying because she also
tries to calm tree down by saying I know
today is hard with your mom how would
she know that trees mom shared the same
birthday or even that her mom had passed
away it looks like she was doing a lot
more digging than previously indicated
when tree confesses to having already
lived through the day multiple times she
predicts that Laurie had already made a
cupcake for her role it totally crazy
but this is happening to me I swear to
god I'm sure it feels okay okay you made
me a cupcake for my birthday
right look at her face right here it
looks like she's afraid that tree may
have found out her secret plan when she
reveals that someone is trying to kill
her Laurie tries to convince her that
nobody is trying to kill her which is
not a logical response if I were Laurie
in that situation and I was innocent I'd
be asking her why she thinks someone's
trying to kill her and trying to get her
to safety not just telling her that
she's crazy and it's impossible that
someone wants to take her out also she
gets way too offended when tree doesn't
eat the cupcake then there's the
elevator scene where tree goes to see
Gregory the professor she's having an
affair with she runs into Laurie and
Laurie tells her that there will be
consequences for her actions but what we
don't know at that point is that the
consequences will be death and the
reason is that Laurie also has a crush
on Gregory the most obvious one though
should have been that Laurie hides out
in the bathroom when tree locks herself
in the room that's where we see the
remote scene Laurie is the only one who
would have access to that room without
looking suspicious and by being trees
only roommate she pretty much gets a
guarantee that tree will be alone and
then finally in the scene where tree is
locked in the cop car Laurie drops a
birthday candle onto a trail of gasoline
to blow up the car the only other candle
we see is the one on Laurie's cupcake
and it's actually not the same candle
though there are different colors and
they look totally different
so that actually threw some doubt into
my
the time and made me think it wasn't
Lorene I actually kind of thought that
it was Danielle because the scene where
she crosses Danielle off the suspect
list the to get hit by a bus which
seemed like more of an accident than a
killing
why would Danielle kill herself if she
just wanted to off tree I don't think
that lorry was behind it either I just
think that she died by coincidence that
time what's not a coincidence however
are the footsteps I hear behind me right
now
what's Dakota why are you trying to kill
me hold on I can explain okay
you know you know when you borrowed ten
dollars of the underground turtle ring
yeah you told me you're making a things
you missed on happy deathday so I came
up with this genius plan on how to get
ten dollars every single day by making
you think you kept reliving the same day
over and over again and I did and now I
have $40 you know Dakota like I would be
mad about that but that's one of the
least lazy things that you've actually
done but I'm still gonna beat the crap
buttons in the original happy deathday
ending just when it seems that tree has
made it out of the woods in advance to
the next day as she's resting in the
hospital somebody in the baby mask comes
up and pokes a syringe into her killing
her once more it's revealed to be
Gregory's wife I usually like dark
endings but I'm glad they changed it to
what it is today and if you agree go
ahead and drop a like on this video I
really did film that three and challenge
video with West Dakota so click this
card to go check that one out and
remember to subscribe to see ZZZ world
for new Horrors twice a week in October
bring that death Bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we make it to tomorrow